اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النشره المفصله
من العربيه يجري الزعيمان الروسيه
في موسكو حول مجموعه من القضايا اهمها
العلاقه الثنائيه والاقتصاد والوضع الدولي
والازمه الاوكرانيه وستبدا المحادثات بين
رئيسين الروسي والصيني في صيغه المصغره
ومن المنتظر ان تكون بحضور وزير الخارجيه
ونائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ووزير الدفاع كذلك من المقرر ان يوقع
الجانبان الروسي والصيني على ما يقرب من
عشر وثائق مشتركه بما في ذلك وثيقه
وهما بيان مشترك حول تعميق الشراكه
والتفاعل الاستراتيجي لما يتوائم مع
الدخول في حقبه جديده وبيان اخر حول خطه
التنميه للمجالات الرئيسيه للتعاون
الاقتصادي لعام 2030 ووصل رئيس الصين الى
موسكو امس الثلاثاء في زياره تستمر حتى
يوم غد الاربعاء وهي اول رحله يقوم بها
الخارج منذ اعاده انتخابه رئيسا للصين
على طاوله الزعيمين الروسي والصيني ملفات
كثيره شراكه وتعاون وغرب يجتمعان عليه من
طول الصين اهميه كبيره للعلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه وهناك منطق تاريخي وراء ذلك لاننا
اكبر دولتين متجاورتين بالاضافه الى اننا
شركاء استراتيجيون
يساهم تفاعلنا على الساحه الدوليه بشكل
عام بالطبع في تعزيز المبادئ الاساسيه
لنظام العالمي وتعدد الاقطاب
[موسيقى]
مع هذه الزياره اعلنت وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه عن تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
ومعدات بقيمه 350 مليون دولار
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا او فرنسا والمانيا لا
يمكنهم لعبوا دوري الوسيط في عمليه السلام
في اوكرانيا كونهم مشاركين في الصراع مع
روسيا على اراضي اوكرانيا حسب قولها وفي
وقت سابق دعا الرئيس السابق لمؤتمر ميونخ
الامن فولفانك الى انشاء مجموعه اتصال حول
اوكرانيا من اجل اطلاق عمليه السلام ومن
المفترض ان تضم المجموعه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا
واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه ان الدول المشار
اليها فرضت عقوبات غير قانونيه على روسيا
وجمدت اصولها الخارجيه وطالبت بانشاء
محكمه لمعاقبه القياده الروسيه
مشددا ايضا انها تدعم مبادرات للسلام
الزائفه حسب قولها وتريد مطالب نهائيه
الاستسلام روسيا بمعزل عن الواقع
مرحبا احمد بالفعل اليوم هو اليوم الثاني
للزياره هو اليوم الرئيسي سيكون هناك
اجتماعات متعدده بعد اللقاء الثنائي وجها
لوجه يوم امس الذي استمر بين الرئيسين
اكثر من 4 ساعات اليوم جدول الاعمال
الرئيس السيسي سيكون في لقاء يبتدائيه مع
رئيس الحكومه
الروسي فيما بعد في الساعه الثانيه عشره
بتوقيت جرينتش سيكون هناك في
تعارف بين وفضي الجانبين وفيما بعد سيكون
هناك اصدقاء ضيق وفيما بعد سيكون لقاء
موسع بين الوفدين وسيكون سيحضره طبعا وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه ووزير الدفاع
بالاضافه الى فيما بعد سيكون هناك تواجد
ايضا للنواب رئيس الحكومه الروسيه
المسؤولين عن قضايا الطاقه وقضايا الماليه
طبعا فيما بعد سيكون هناك ايضا تو قيع
لوثائق وبيان مشترك وينتهي اللقاء بمؤتمر
صحفي سيعقده الزعيمان الروسي والصيني طبعا
كما تحدث الخبراء ووسائل الاعلام التي
تناولت اليوم بكثره اللقاء او القمه
الروسيه الصينيه تحدثت عن ان هذا اللقاء
وهذه الزياره
الاتصال مع الزميره كاتيما سنحاول ان نعود
اليها في سياق هذه النشره ونشر المشاهدين
الى هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا على الوكاله
التاسع التي تقول ان رئيس الوزراء الروسي
يستقبل الرئيس الصيني في هذه اللحظات
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انا انفجار
وقع في مدينه جانكوي في شمال شبه جزيره
القرم ادى لتدمير صواريخ كروز من طراز
كاليبر ان كان الاسطول الروسي في البحر
الاسود يعتزم استخدامها وذلك اثناء عمليه
نقلها عبر السكك الحديديه واوضحت اداره
المخابرات الرئيسيه بالوزاره ان هذه
الصواريخ مصممه لاطلاق بل للاطلاق من سفن
سطحيه تابعه لاصول السؤال الروسي في البحر
الاسود ويبلغ بداها التشغيل اكثر من
2500 كم على الارض
و375 كيلومترا في البحر
هذا هو اخر السلطات القرم بوقوع هجمات
بمسيره اوكراني استهدفت السككا حديريه
وبنيه التحتيه في شمال شبه الجزيره وذكر
مسؤول برئاسه القرم ان السكك الحديديه
والبنيه التحتيه والقطارات لم تتضرر وتعمل
وفقا للمواعيد المحدده بعد تفعيل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي مشيرا الى اصابه احد السكان
بشظايا بسبب حطام هذه المسيرات
هذا مشاهدينا واعلنت ايضا القوات الروسيه
تدميرا معدات اوكرانيه باستخدام نظام
الصواريخ المضاده لدبابات ذاتيه الحركه
خلال القتال بالقرب من مارينكا وقال قائد
المجموعه التكتيكيه المضاده لدبابات
بايكال ان نظام الصواريخ المضاده لدبابات
ذاتيه الحركه يقوم باستطلاع الاهداف
والمراقبه لتحديد وتدمير مركبات العدو
المدرعه وغير المدرعه مؤكدا ان المجموعه
تعمل على منع دبابات العدو من اختراق خط
الدفاع مشيا الى انه تم استخدامه صواريخ
اتاكا
اذا بعد موافقه الاتحاد الاوروبي مشاهدينا
بتخصيص ملياري يورو لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره قال رئيس الاوكراني ان امداد
اوقني بالذخيره من الاتحاد الاوروبي زاد
من ثقته في مسار الصراع التي بل الذي
تشهده المنطقه مؤكدا ان تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي يعد
خطوه استراتيجيه للانتصار على الدوله
المعتديه على
حد وصفها نتابع
توفير الذخيره من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
خطوه استراتيجيه تزيد من الثقه في وحداتنا
للانتصار على الدوله المعتديه انا ممتن
لجميع شركائنا في اوروبا ولجميع المهتمين
حقا باوروبا القويه والحره
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البولندي عن افتتاح
اول قاعده عسكريه امريكيه دائما في مدينه
بوزنان واوضحت الوزهر في بيانها ان مهمه
القاعده الرئيسيه هي التنسيق والاشراف على
القوات البريه الامريكيه في اوروبا
والتخطيط العملياتي وتنسيق التعاون
والتزامن بين القوات الامريكيه وقوات دول
الناتو الاخرى ومن جهته ذكر مسؤول في
البنتا ان القاعده الامريكيه في بولندا
تهدف لدعم البنيه التحتيه العسكريه وقياده
واداره المواقع المتقدمه للقوات هناك
مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا السيد محمد العروقي
رئيس تحرير موقع اوكرانيا
اليوميه جديده اعلنت عنها وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه في عمق جزيره القرم بدايه كيف
قرات هذه العمليه من حيث التوقيت والدلاله
منطقه
بعض المشاكل المدنيه سيد محمد اعتذر منك
هناك مشكله في الصوت من المصدر لا يصون
بشكل واضح سنعود اليك بعد صيانه او مراجعه
هذا هذه المشكله سنعود اليك مره اخرى سيد
محمد تحياتي اليك مشاهدينا مع نهايه
الاجتماع العالمي في لندن لبحث معاقبه
مجرمي الحرب حتى الرئيس الاوكرانيزيا
الاسكي المشاركين في المؤتمر على دعم كافه
العناصر الدوريه لمعاقبه المعتدين على
اوكرانيا مشددا على ضروره تحقيق عقوبه
عادله وقانونيه قبل المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لهذه الجرائم التي ادت لهذه الحرب
التي تشهدها البلاد
هناك حاجه لعقوبه عادله وقانونيه تماما
لهذه الجريمه التي ادت الى جميع الجرائم
الاخرى لهذه الحرب وهذا ما ستقوم به
المحكمه الخاصه خلال مؤتمر وزراء العد
الاوروبيين نوقشت هذه المساله وقد خاطبت
المشاركين في المؤتمر لحذفهم على دعم كافه
عناصر الجهود الدوليه لمعاقبه المعتدين
نعود اليك مره اخرى من كيف معنا السيد
محمد العروقي رئيس تحرير موقع اوكرانيا
اليوم سيد محمد كنت تتحدث قبل قليل عن
رؤيتين مختلفتين او روايتين مختلفتين من
الجانب الروسي والجانب الاوكراني حول هجوم
القرم تفضل
نعم اريد ان اكمل الصوره يعني ان هناك
يعني روايتين تقول ان هناك عزومه يعني على
المدنيين بطائرات مسيره شخص ما المصادر
الاوكرانيه الامنيه والعسكريه تريد انه تم
يعني مهاجمه الحديديه يحمل بعض الاسلحه
وبعض المواد مثل الصواريخ الباليستيه
وتواريخ يعني حقيقه هذا ياتي في وقت
تتصاعد فيه الاوضاع في الشرق اوكرانيا
سواء على الصعيد العسكري وفي الوقت تشهد
المنطقه حراك يعني دبلوماسي فقط قبل ان
تفوتني يعني الفكره اود ان اضيف ان هذه
المنطقه التي تم التي قصفت امس يعني منطقه
استراتيجيه جدا بها ملتقى جميع السككه
الحديديه التي تخرج الى المدن في شبه
جزيره القرن فبالتالي اعتقد ان يعني هذه
الخطوه جاءت يعني بعد زياره قام بها
الرئيس بوتين الى القرن واجزاء الى الى
منطقه وفي اليوم الذي امس واليوم الزعيم
الصيني في موسكو اعتقد يعني هذه لها
تداعيات ستكون المستقبل وهي رساله ايضا
الى ان الجانب الاوكراني اذا كان هو
المسؤول عن هذه العمليه يعني انه يعتبر
جزيره القرن هي ارض اوكرانيه محتله
يعني هذا هجوميه ايضا بعد اسابيع قليله من
حديث ادلت به
نائبه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قالت فيها
العسكريه في روسيا هي اهداف او في شبه
القرم تحديدا هي اهداف مشروعه لاوكرانيا
وان اوكرانيا لن تكون امنه
القضاء على السلاح شبه جزيره القرم حسب
تعبيرها هل يمكن الحديث استنادا على هذه
التصريحات عن دور امريكي او بصمه امريكيه
في هذا الهجوم ولو حتى لو كانت عن طريق
الدعم اللوجستي الذي يقدم لاوكرانيا
عن طريق الاقمار الصناعيه والاتصالات
والتوجيه من بدايه هذه الحرب وهذا كان له
كبيرا على يعني للجيش الاوكراني في احراج
بعد الانتصارات او بعد التقدم الملموس على
القوات الروسيه ولكن لا اعتقد انه يوجد
هناك اي سلاح غربي حتى الان يعني يستخدمها
اوكرانيا من مهاجمه مناطق تعتبرها روسيا
تتبع لسيادتها فبالتالي يعني السبب اي دعم
عسكري او اي اسلحه غربيه استخدمتها
اوكرانيا اذا كانت هي مسؤوله عن هذا العمل
في الاراضي الروسيه
اما اوكرانيا لديها من الاسلحه
التي اشتهدت في تطويرها وقد استخدمتها
سابقا واتت يعني بنتائج طيبه فبالتالي
اعتقد ان يعني هذه الامور خالصه بالسلاح
اوكرانيا
اعتذر منك كيف كنت معنا سيد محمد وعروقي
رئيس تحرير موقع اوكرانيا اليوم
اعلنت روسيا بحق المدعي العام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وثلاثه من قضتها بعد
ايام على اصدارهم مذكرها توقيف بحق رئيس
روسيا بتهم ارتكاب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
وقالت لجنه التحقيق الروسيه في بيان ان
هؤلاء القضاه وبينهم المدعي العام للمحكمه
كريم خان اصدار قرارات غير قانونيه لتوقيف
رئيس الاتحاد الروسي ومفاوضه حقوق الاطفال
مؤكده بانه تم فتح تحقيق جنائي بحقهم وكان
مدعي عام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوريه كريم
خان قال ان اوامر اعتقال الرئيس الروسي
التي صدرت عين المحكمه
مناسبه بل مناسبه حزينه على حد تعبيره
نتابع
حزينه للغايه حيث شعر قضاه المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه للمره الاولى على
الاطلاق بضروره اصدار اوامر اعتقال ضد
زعيم وكبار مسؤول دوله هي عضو دائم في
مجلس الامن ومن المؤس ان الذين لديهم
تاريخ رائع ولكن ايضا من المفترض ان يكون
الاوصياء على ميثاق الامم المتحده
يبدا اليوم رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شيعه السوداني زياره الى تركيا تستمر
يومين واشارت مصاديو العربيه الى ان
السودان سيناقش في تركيا عدد من ملفات
اهمها ضبط الحدود والمياه وانتشار حزب
العمق كردستاني على الاراضي العراقيه
وملفات سياسيه واقتصاديه وقال السوداني في
تصريحات لصحيفه ديل صباح التركيه انه
سيبحث في انقره كيفيه التعاون والتنسيق
لضمان حصول العراق على احتياجاتهم المياه
شريان حياه للتنميه والتوسع الزراعيه
ومع مرور الذكرى العشرين على الغزو
الامريكي العراق اكد السفير الامريكي
والمبعوث الرئاسي السابق الى العراق ان
الاستخبارات افادت حينها بان صدام حسين
كان يسعى الى امتلاك اسلحه الدمار الشامل
الا انه من الواضح ان هذا لم يكن صحيحا
وفق ما صرح به في لقاء مع صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط واكد بريمر ان الوكاله ان الوكالات
الاستخباريه الامريكيه لم تكن الوحيده
التي هي على ثقه من هذا الامر انما معها
الفرنسيون والالمان والبراطيه
والبريطانيون والروس وعلى ذلك اتفقت
وكالات استخبارات هذه الدول على عمليه
الغزو مشيرا الى ان بوش ادرك تداعيات
القرار لكن هدفه كان مساعده العراقيين على
استعاده بلادهم اقتصاديا وسياسيا على حد
وصفه
ارسلها ثلاثه رؤساء لجان في مجلس النواب
الامريكي خطابا الى المدعي العام في منحاه
الديمقراطيه يطالبونه فيه بالادلاء
بشهادته وتقديم نسخ ومعلومات حول التهم
الموجهه الى ترامب والتي وصفوها بانها
اساءه غير مسبوقه لسلطه الادعاء العام لكن
يبدو انه من غير مرجح ان يستجيب كل من
براج ووزاره العدل هذا الطلب نظرا
للممارسه طويله الامد المتمثله في عدم
افشاء المدعين لمعلومات حول القضايا
الحساسه
ان الرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب
لن يتم تكبير يديه اذا وجه رسميا ضده
الاتهام في نيويوركا ونقلت الوكاله عن
مصدر مطلع انه على الرغم من ان ترامب
سيتخذ بل سيتم اخذ بصمات اصابعه وتصويره
بشكل جانبي وامامي الا انه لن يتم تقييد
يديه امام الكاميرات او وضعه في زنزانه
مضيفا انه من المحتمل ان يظل رهن الاحتجاز
تحت حراسه جهاز سري سيكون مكلفا بحمايته
من جهته قال حاكم فلوريدا انه لن يتورط في
عمليه تسليم ترامب الى سلطه نيويورك وفقا
لمسؤولين امريكيين فان اجراءات التخطيط
الداخلي للتعامل مع الرئيس السابق سيكون
باعتقاله اذا لم يستسلم
نشاطنا مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
بايدن يصدر قانونا يرفع سريه عن وثائق
استخباراتيه امريكيه عن منشئ كورونا
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افاد مراسل
العربيه في باريس بان حاله من الفوضى
العارمه تعم شوارع العاصمه وعددا بل تعم
عددا من المدن الفرنسيه بعد تمرير قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد وفي العاصمه الفرنسيه
اطلقت قوات الشرطه الغاز البوسي للدموع
وقامت بعمليه اعتقال عشوائيه في صفوف
محتجين القانون وفيما ادرى محتجون النيران
في عدد من الاماكن دعا سياسيونه فرنسيون
الى النزول الى الشوارع مطالبين رئيسه
الوزراء بالاستقاله
رحب الاتحاد الاوروبي باتفاق تبادل الاسرى
في اليمن ودع الاتحاد الى الافراج عن جميع
السجناء والبناء على هذه الخطوه لتحقيق
السلام الدائم في البلاد وكان ممثلون عن
الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين اتفقوا امس على
اطلاق سراح
887 اسيرا كمرحله الاولى بعد مفاوضات في
جناب برعايه الامم المتحده واللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
كشفت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل بنيامين سينياهو تلقى رسائل
من مسؤولين كبار في اداره بايدن لنصحه
بعدم بل تنصحه بعدم زياره واشنطن في الوقت
الراهن مع اتساع احتياجات الداخليه ضد
قانون تغيير النظام القضائي وقالت اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي في تقريرها عبر تويتر
قالت ان المسؤولين الامريكيين حذروا
لتنيئاهم انه سيواجه انتقادات على نياء
اذا جاء الى البيت الابيض
افاد مسؤولون كبير في الاداره الامريكيه
لوكاله رويترز ان توقف رئيسه تايوان
المتوقع في الولايات المتحده في الاسابيع
المقبله ممارسه معتاده وعلى الصين الا
تستخدم هذا رعاه للقيام بعمل عدواني تجاه
الجزيره حيث تخطط تساعي للعبور نيويورك
كجزء من رحله الى امريكا الوسطى وقالت
مصادرز ان رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
يعتزم مقابلتها خلال الزياره التي تقوم
بها
اصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قانونا
يرفع السريه عن معلومات استخباراتيه حول
وجود روابط محتمله بين منشئ فيروس كورونا
ومختبر في مدينه وهران الصينيه
روابط محتمله معهد اوهان لعلم الفيروسات
واضاف ان ادارته سترفع السريه وستنشر اكبر
قدر ممكن من المعلومات
عندما يدخل شهر مارس تبدا المتاجر في
استقبال الراغبين في شراء هدايا عيد الام
ولكن يتزامن ايضا مع دخول شهر رمضان وقد
يكون هذا من اسباب محاوله الابناء شراء
هدايا تجمع المناسبتين
هذا العام سبق عيد الام شهر رمضان بيومين
فرصه ثانويه لشراء الهدايا للامهات فكيف
تاثرت بدخول رمضان بعض الابناء يحاولون
شراء هديه تجمع المناسبتين ولهذا يلجاون
للاماكن التي تبيع منتجات يدويه الصنع انا
جايه انا ومامتي علشان لو حاجه هي بتحب
الحاجات اللي [__] والهند والحاجات دي فان
لو عجبتها هجيب لها حاجات عشان عيد الام
بعض منتجي السلعه اليدويه استعدوا من خلال
تصميمات ذات علاقه بالمناسبتين معا وفي
هذه الحاله وجدنا الكثير من مندمج رمضان
في عيد الام اللي بيدور على يد الام
موجوده بيدور على رمضان موجود في حاجات
عاملاها ميكس ما بين الاثنين يعني زي مثلا
كاتبه عليها رمضان احلى مع جدتي رمضان
احلى مع امي فتبقى هديه الاثنين مع بعض
عيد الام ورمضان كل فتره من دول بيبقى
ليها فيه معين في البيت فمثلا في رمضان
كلنا بنجهز ديكورات رمضان والبيت كله
بيقلب ديكورات رمضان ونشيل الديكورات
العاديه
في كريسماس برضه البيت كله يعني اعتقد ان
هي السيزون دي بتبقى حلوه يعني وسواء
تزامن عيد الام مع رمضان ام لا فدائما ما
تستعد ومتاجر وبيع الزهور كل عام بكميات
كبيره من السلعه الاكثر مبيعا في هذه
المناسبه تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
احتفلت قناه العربيه في الرياض بمرور
عشرين عاما على تاسيسها الذي كان في مارس
من العام 2003 الحفل شهد حضورا لوزراء
ومسؤولين رفيعي المستوى من المنطقه
واستذكر رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ
بدايات التاسيس للقناه والطريقه الصعب
الذي سلكته للوصول الى ما هي عليه اليوم
في حين استعرض الرئيس التنفيذي لمجموعه ام
بي سي سامبارد النجاحات التي راكمتها
القناه طوال عقدين كما تحدث المدير العام
لقناه العربيه والحدث عن نهج الاعتدال
الذي ما زالت القناه تعتبره منهجا لطرحها
الحفل شهد ايضا حضورا لابرز الاعلاميين
وصناع الراي في العالم العربي
وراء كل خبر قصه تروى تدقيق ورصد بالصوره
شاشه يمتد عمرها لاكثر من عشرين عاما ان
تعرف اكثر مهمه العربيه من عام لاخر الان
جاء دور الصوت والكلمه من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض ولدت اذاعه العربيه
العربيه اف ام تضعك في الصوره لتعرف اكثر
ومن قلب استديوهات الاخبار بالرياض اذاعه
العربيه تكمل الصوره خبرا لكل المستمعين
فصلكم حيثما كنتم اسرع من اي وقت مضى
اتمنى ان يصلكم الخبر فور حدوثه واينما
كنتم بالصوت والكلمه سنقدم لك كل ما يهمك
ان تعرفه عبر صباح العربيه
لطالما كانت الفكره وتفرد المحتوى هما حجر
الزاويه منذ نشاه العربيه تواصل الخزاعه
المشوار بخطه ثابته في بث يمتد عبر الاثير
والوسائط المتعدده الى مستمعيها في العالم
اجمع
عصام عبد السلام اذاعه العربيه اف ام
وفي نهايه هذه النص المشاهدين نذكر بابرز
العناوين
على وقع زياره الرئيس الصيني لموسكو شحنه
صواريخ روسيه اثناء نقلها للقرم
مع مرور عقدين على الغزو الامريكي مبعوث
بوش يؤكد ان العراق لم يكن لديه اسلحه
دمار شامل
وواسطه توقعات بقرب توجيه الاتهام للترامب
الولايات المتحده تستعد للثلاثاء الكبير
وتتحسب لخروج انصاره
مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]